this is a production of Cornell
University
the title of my talk today is variation
survival mechanisms of wild and
cultivated grapevine and I just wanted
to point out that I don't like to work
with grape vines when they're ugly green
and filled with fruit but I prefer to be
out in the field in the middle of the
winter when it's really comfortable and
the vines look like they're dead but
before we get into the actual research I
wanted to give a little bit more of an
enhanced introduction to myself as was
brought up my backgrounds in molecular
biology and plant biology in particular
but my graduate and postdoctoral work
was mostly in population genetics and
population ecology and I worked with
cultivated and wild rice and then as I
moved on in my post stock I worked with
bent grass and canola and so I've had a
lot of experience jumping around in
different plant systems and always from
a population biology standpoint so I
like to understand crops in their wild
ancestors and the traits that we've
managed to select from the wild and then
use for crop improvement throughout my
studies I've always been very interested
in adaptation and the evolution of
stress responses and plants I just think
it's particularly interesting that
plants can't remove themselves from a
stressful situation they have to adapt
or they die and so in the past I've
worked on a number of different
stressful conditions from the plants
point of view including aluminum
tolerance and rice and herbicide
resistance and drought resistance in
canola and Ben crass the other thing I
wanted to make a point of is that in
jumping around in these different
systems and looking at population
genetics and population ecology I tend
to also move between the lab and the
field frequently and so I I've got a
good set of molecular hands but I also
tend to do a lot of experimental work
out in the field and in greenhouses like
our picture down here on the bottom
right to set up stressful conditions and
try to model how the climate might be
changing and affecting plant growth so
then I just wanted to also introduce the
usda-ars Gigi are you or the great
genetics research unit we're based up on
the Cornell extension campus in Geneva
inside GG are you we have two major
research programs which are title up
here we have a research program looking
at improving grapefruit stock and Scion
pest and disease resistance and the
second program called the genetics and
genomics of great growth development and
quality this is the program that I work
in inclusive of these two programs there
are five research scientist with
associated support staff gani wang chung
is our research leader and he focuses on
functional genomics landscape davidson
focuses on biotic stress genetics
particularly powdery mildew and downy
mildew of grapevine Chris Owens focuses
on fruit quality genetics Angela baldo
is our computational biologist and as
was pointed out I joined the group a
year ago and my focus is a biotic stress
genetics with focus on cold tolerance
but also dabbling in drought resistance
and salinity resistance so just as a
primer in case anybody isn't familiar
with grapevines vidis venafro cultivated
grapevine is one of the most important
horticultural fruit crops that we grow
it's consumed as fresh fruit dried for
raisins or press press for juice or
fermented in wine and actually about 71
percent of the grapes that are grown are
grown for wine production grapevine is
really interesting from a population
genetics and population ecology point of
view there are thousands of cultivars
grown across the world but many of them
are ancient they there was something
perfect about growing conditions
thousands of years ago that farmers
vegetatively propagated a certain set of
cultivars time and time again and now
those cultivars are grown across the
planet in a number of different
environments this is really interesting
from the point of view of abiotic stress
adaptation we also have a sequence
genome that allows us to start applying
molecular and genetic tools towards
understanding how traits are inherited
traits are expressed
from the population biology point of
view there are three different gene
pools in the genus vidis in Asia there's
approximately 40 species there's about
two European species vidis Vanaras the
cultivated grape and its wild ancestors
also consider European and in North
America we have roughly 20 species and
these numbers change a little bit
depending on who you talk to you but
this is the general layout of wild vidis
at the USDA in Geneva we maintain the
cold hardy grape germ plasm for the
United States I think we have roughly
sixteen hundred different genotypes of
which we have all the cold hardy
varieties I've listed some of the
species here in the bottom right and
these are species names that I'll be
using throughout the rest of my talk
because esta vollis scenario labrasca
ripe area rupesh Thurston vol penna and
to give you an idea of the distribution
of these species I've placed three of
them on on the board here vitis or Perry
is in the top left corner and if you can
see the the lime green is a county-level
distribution of where you can find ripe
area records of ripe area you can see
it's really diverse in the type of
climates that it could be inhabiting in
the u.s. all the way from southern
Louisiana to Manitoba in Quebec and west
to east from Colorado and Montana to the
Northeast you can imagine a lot of
different climate gradients exist in
that swath of geography so there's a lot
of potential for wild greatest sessions
to carry unique adaptations to some of
these abiotic stresses that I'm tasked
with working on
I also put up vitis labrasca and buys
estabas just as another comparison and
that almost all of these wild species
have a very wide geographic range so all
of the different species have the
potential to be mined for important
traits I wanted to mention that cold
stress response and hardiness is a
really complex topic there's lots of
different traits that could be playing a
role and lots of different time points
throughout the growing season that cold
stress could be important it's important
to note that cold stress is tissue
dependent if you look at green tissues
versus dormant tissues what the plant
perceives as a cold stress could be very
different routes versus shoots perceive
temperature salinity drought all very
different so you have to kind of dial
down and figure out which traits are
going to be workable there's also a
bastard array of mechanical and
molecular mechanisms that contribute to
cold hardiness if you can remove a
damaged plant Oregon and avoid a cold
shock it's one potential way to get
around damn it or sustained damage or
you could have an army of molecular
chaperones that help stabilize membranes
and proteins when the plan is undergoing
a cold shock down on the bottom of the
screen is my attempt to draw a growth
cycle what I'm trying to illustrate here
is that as the plants go from winter to
spring through summer to fall and back
into winter there are different points
in the growing season that cold can
affect the plant survival in winter we
could have very sharp drops in
temperature that kill dormant tissues
and in the spring after budburst frost
unseasonal are unsuitable through skin
damage green tissues the same thing can
occur in a fall prior to plants having
enough time to acclimate and go to sleep
before the the coming winter these sort
of stresses the tissue dependence and
the difference in defense mechanisms are
shared across perennial species and
there's lots of variation in what
tactics were
work for different model systems but in
one general theme are these cold binding
factor genes which are transcription
factors that seem to be activated by
cold and drought stress and create a
molecular cascade of defense responses
the whole point of cold tolerance in
growing tissues is to prevent ice
formation from forming inside of living
cells and so this is also my personal
attempt to draw what cold damage looks
like i don't have an art degree this is
a plant cell on the left with a an
attempt at thylakoids mitochondria
nucleus just imagine there's lots of
different plant Oregon or cell organs
inside as the plant perceives freezing
stress it tries to export water to
prevent the chance of ice forming inside
the living cell water can freeze outside
of cells and not damage the living
tissue and so this is called the
high-temperature exotherm where ice
freezes and doesn't cause lethal damage
but as temperature continues to decrease
the ice creates a water gradient that
causes water to continuously be pulled
from the cell and so the cell starts to
be stressed by dehydration and if
dehydration becomes extreme you can
start having membranes fusing together
at some point the molecular and
mechanical mechanisms that are defenses
that are mounted to prevent ice
formation within the cell fail at and
you have ice crystals formats in the
living cell causing lethal damage and
this is called a low-temperature
exotherm if you happen to avoid this say
it gets warmer water can re-enter the
cell as the gradient is switched and if
your membranes have fuse together you
can have lethal damage even though the
plant tissue didn't freeze solid because
as the membranes re expand they rip
apart and so you lose all your function
so there's a whole list of potential
mechanisms to prevent this cascade from
happening there's avoidance mechanisms
like super cooling transporting the
water out of the cell formation of sugar
glasses to keep membranes apart tissue
barriers as I mentioned before there's
also mechanisms that are typically
called tolerance mechanisms where
membranes may change their polarity
there may be chaperones and placed
inside membranes to prevent them from
fusing with one another cryoprotective
proteins could be produced help
stabilize protein function and
compatible solute could be produced to
increase the cells of bill or the plant
cells ability to hold on to water even
when there is a water gradient this is
what it looks like if you try to put it
into molecular terms the whole process
of coal and dehydration stress so you
can see it's a big mess Green Arrow's
our promoter arrows red were pressured
signs our genes that function as
repressors what I wanted to just bring
up was that you have cold or changes in
light or dehydration some sort of
external stimuli it leads to a
transcription factor cascade that
culminates here in the CBF regulon
remember I mentioned the cold binding
factor genes these genes activate a
whole series of downstream genes called
core genes and kin genes many of which
we don't know what they do other than
they lead to the production of
cryoprotectants and compatible solute
sometimes solid with sugars all which
are thought to help with that prevention
of lethal dehydration and ice formation
within the cell
so there's many different aspects of
cold stress and hardiness there's
dormancy and reduced d acclamation so
how the plant perceives winter's coming
how it goes to sleep and then
reactivates in the summer or the spring
midwinter bud survival is understanding
how buds can survive lower and lower
temperatures without having that
internal ice currents and then survival
against spring and spring and fall frost
but one thing that pops in my mind is
maybe we don't need to worry about cold
tolerance if climate change is occurring
in global temperatures are rising we
just need to wait a couple more years
and then winters will be 70 and there's
no reason for me to have a job but if
you think about the way that climate
change is predicted to occur there are
supposed to be more and more erratic
weather patterns and so there's the
potential for rapid changes in
temperature exposing green tissues to
freezing conditions and this is an
example of what hap when that happens
this is pictures from space in 2006 if
we look at early April what the
phonology of the United States looks
like verses 20 days roughly 20 days
later you can see that there's a lot
more leaves Lamar budburst in those 20
days My Jesus is from space but this is
what it looks like in April of the
following year after they've had a very
very warm month of March so phonology is
advanced by several weeks and the scent
must sound very similar to what we had
this past year so if in all energy gets
advanced a month early then we have a
return to normal cold spring
temperatures that wipes out early green
tissues and so you can see that the the
dark green has been completely reset to
the lighter green showing you that
there's been a lot of damage it's
estimated that this particular Easter
freeze cause somewhere around two
billion dollars worth of agriculture and
horticultural damage impacting lots of
our standard crops wheat rye barley and
corn and then all of our fruit crops
which are listed down here at the bottom
so this is the sort of climate Swift
changes in climate that we're worried
about as far as cold tolerance goes this
is why I should keep my job so green
tissues are very cold tender and they
can't survive long bouts of freezing and
on grapes this is important to note
because grapes are primarily fruitful in
the primary bud the inflorescence
meristems are laid down the year before
and so whatever birth saw that primary
bud is where you're going to get your
fruit and your harvest from so if you
get a killing frost in the early spring
that kills off the first bud the plants
will usually survive because they'll
push buds from secondary and tertiary
buds but there'll be far less fruitful
if they produce fruit at all so this is
really bad from the farmers point of
view and this just illustrates what that
sort of frost kill looks like so that's
the end of the background I was just
going to now tell you about three sort
of preliminary studies that we're
conducting to try to get at looking at
cold grapevine cold tolerance the first
one's going to be looking at dormancy
chilling and D acclamation and wild
grape vine then we're going to look a
little bit at mid-water midwinter bud
hardiness and finish up with a little
discussion on osmotic mechanisms that
could be contributing to mid winter
hardiness so to start acclamation and
dormancy and I apologize if this is a
little too redundant i'm not sure where
everybody is on cold tolerance so as far
as dormancy goes from the prospect or
from the point of view from the plant
there are several different stages
during the growing season basil buds are
thought of as being para dormant which
is right here where apical buds are
suppressing the growth of those buds
through hormone control as the plants
enter fall and they start receiving
lower temperature cues and light
temperature cues you have a chance in
molecular and metabolic status that
tells the plan to start going to sleep
so this is called endo dormancy once the
plants gun fully to sleep
but we really haven't gotten to the
middle of winter here the final stage of
dormancy is ecostore eco dormancy this
occurs after endo dormancy has been
fulfilled by currently some unknown
factor and the plant is ready to grow
the only thing keeping it from growing
is the fact that it's still winter so
that environmental parameters of growth
are not favorable when those are lifted
growth resumes in the spring and so this
is sort of what the curve in dormancy
looks like pictured here on the bottom
left acclamation takes place over
several months the deepest hardiness and
dormancy occurs in the middle of the
winter and then as you enter spring d
acclamation and resumption of growth
occurs at a much faster rate than the
plant took to become acclimated in the
beginning in the beginning of the year
the amount of cold that the plant needs
to experience to fulfill endo dormancy
is important because if the plant
doesn't achieve that magical number when
you return to growing conditions in the
spring buds will not burst synchronously
so you'll have growth occur on grape
vines but they'll it'll be a spotty one
bud here one bud there d synchronized
budburst leads to very d synchronize
flowering and d synchronize fruiting
desynchronized ripening and so farmers
don't want to be harvesting grapes at
multiple time points in the fall they
want to go through and get it all at
once so it's very important to have
grape vines that are able to satisfy the
endoderm and see the chilling
requirement prior to the growing season
depending on where they are so this
leads us to this idea of a dream
grapevine so if you're growing grapes in
a warm climate you want a grapevine that
goes to sleep in the winter but only
needs a small winner because you only
have a small winner and that will
leading to grapevines of them burst
synchronously in the spring in cold
climates we don't mind so much how long
the chilling hours are because our
winners are plenty long what we want is
a grapevine that comes out of dormancy
and kind of takes its time slows itself
down because otherwise you end up with
what we ended up last year you have
grapevines pushing in the early spring
followed by side
frost and we lose part of our crop so it
depends on where you're going grape
vines on what sort of traits you're
looking for so we do to assess chilling
requirement in wild grape vines as we go
out to the germplasm in November early
November and take cuttings right after
the first killing frost the one that the
frost that knocks down the leaves we
collect a whole bunch of canes and put
them in a cold room at five degrees C 5
degree C is sort of the sweet spot for
the cold clock in grape as long as
they're held at five degrees or lower
they start counting towards the end of
that endoderm NC we then take the
cuttings out of the cold room at several
time points during the winter and put
them in forcing conditions and see if
they're ready if they filled that end of
dormancy time limit this is just on the
picture on the left here is what the
experiment looks like it's just a bunch
of cuttings in a growth chamber and we
go down and assess whether or not
they're growing this is what the data
looks like from one of these experiments
pictured here is results from the
cultivated grapevine cabernet sauvignon
and we have sort of a randomly chosen
time point to assess when endo dormancy
has ended and that's at at four weeks if
fifty percent of the buds have burst
after four weeks in forcing conditions
we consider endo dormancy to be
fulfilled and so you can see here that
for Cabernet Sauvignon we don't really
call the fifty percent budburst until I
owe ya Geneva can't see my pointer I
keep reading it I would say around a
thousand hours of cold so if you look at
this graph the far right line is the
darkest red line that's zero hours in
the cold we cut it from the field put it
in a growth chamber and then as you step
back in lines and in more and more pink
color these are time points where the
cuttings have been in the cold room for
longer and longer period of time so you
can see that it takes about a thousand
hours or cabernet sauvignon to be ready
to burst the other thing I want you to
note is the longer that you keep them in
the
hold the faster they burst and the more
synchronous they burst so there's a
couple different clocks going on here an
ultimate clock and then one that you can
speed up over time that's kind of the
that's kind of the journal level cut off
for endodermis ease fifty percent bud
burst at four weeks enforcing conditions
that it could be a little subjective
though so I'm not going to show you tons
and tons of graphs but I wanted to show
how we have variation within the germ
plasm samples that I'm evaluating from
the field we have genotypes that require
very low amount to chillin so on the top
of the slide here we have Riesling and
then wild species video strip area from
Manitoba and you can see for both of
these cultivars that they satisfy their
ended dormancy with very little chilling
and they with increased chillin you
actually have with the ripe area for
manitoba they don't require any start at
seven days they've burst to completion
so they're very fast out of the gates
after a certain amount of cold we also
have gene types that require high
amounts of chilling and here's two wild
species bit is full pen on the left and
bit asleep estrus on the right you can
just see by looking at the distribution
of the lines that they require a lot
more chilling in order to satisfy that
bud burst requirement this is another
way of looking at the data if you look
at if you take all the cuttings that
were placed into the growth chamber
after 500 hours of chilling this is how
how many days if they require before
they burst so it gives you an idea that
there are there are some varieties that
will not burst at all sixty hours
actually means never burst in this
experiment so these buds though they're
totally viable don't burst after eight
weeks without chillin so they need this
chilling in order to get that counter
going over time you can see that they
get better and better and bursting with
increased chillin
the other thing I want you to know is
that there's a big difference between in
this example am your n sis on the bottom
which requires very little chilling and
burst faster and faster and faster and
volcano which requires a lot of chilling
and even after 2000 hours it's increased
its chilling time but it can never
really match the speed of emer ensis and
so there's got to be some genetic
control over the clock and the speed of
that clock picture on the bottom is
three sessions of vid izle penna and
three sections of it a scenario just
demonstrating to you that we have
variation within a species for the
response as well and involve penna you
can see that all three varieties start
out together the same and then as they
accumulate Schilling hours they start to
diverge in their ability to hit any
particular bud burst speed scenario is
kind of opposite in that with very
little chilling the three varieties are
very diverse in their response but then
as they accumulate chilling hours they
converge on a set in this case it's
three weeks to bud burst after 2000
hours so this is just to illustrate some
of the phenotype that we're trying to
understand with dormancy and bud burst
rates and wild germplasm we want to also
understand how this might relate to
midwinter bud hardiness this is the
trait that's been the focus of the
majority of grapevine breeding for cold
hardiness and grapevine breeders have
typically used video stripe area from
northern locations in breeding programs
and it's been very successful in
conveying midwinter bud hardiness and
I've placed up here two examples
Marquette and frost knack both of which
are able to survive the temperatures of
negative 36 degrees Fahrenheit the
problem with this may be that bitter I
perio sessions can be very prone to
early bud break and that put down here
again the Manitoba sample that I showed
you before that after a long winter
they're able to break bud after one week
so in a situation where we have a really
warm March and then a very cold April
something that carries a lot of ripe
area background might be more
susceptible to frost
damage so we want to understand how
genotypes differ and maybe our hardiness
in order to make good breeding decisions
so we assess mid winter hardiness using
digital thermal analysis which is
looking at that low temperature exotherm
that I pointed out in my cartoon the
temperature at which the water freezes
inside cells signaling lethality we do
this by exercising buds from the field
putting them in this nifty programmable
freezer lowering the temperature over
time and as the water inside the bud
goes from liquid to crystal and it
freezes there's a small release of heat
which is registered as a change in
voltage and we're able to observe at
what temperature buds die and so here
pictured in the graph you can see two
strong peaks here these are two primary
buds from to blood cuttings as the
temperature cause lethal damage and then
a very small peak afterwards which is
probably a secondary bud that was still
attached to the cutting secondary and
tertiary buds tend to be a little bit
harder so we can track these hardiness
values throughout the season this is
what last winter looked like these are
daily min and max temperatures with the
freezing point illustrated here in the
horizontal black line I do apologize I
flip between Fahrenheit and Celsius
frequently sorry about that I didn't
realize it until is practicing this just
go with relatives we're always below the
freezing point in these graphs so which
you can see with our winter as it was
pretty warm in November and December got
a little bit chilly than around New
Year's we got a pulse of very cold
weather then another few days of very
very cold weather warmed back up and we
had a super warm March and if you were
to see this go you'd see our April come
crashing back down the other side if we
look at the dta results for vidis
vinifera Cab Franc and riesling these
are the values from this past winter
this is the LT 50 so if the temperature
had dipped down and intersected with one
of these lines we would expect about
fifty percent of the
odds on that plant to have been killed
you can see good news nobody had that
problem in this winter I should also
mention that this is all data that's
been collected in collaboration with Tim
Martinson who runs the extension on the
Geneva campus his group does all the
collection of the buds and the dta runs
and then I do some downstream processing
this is what it looks like if you look
at hybrid varieties concord and waray
you can see a similar pattern to the
vanilla and that they decrease with
temperature over time but then they get
much more responsive to switches in
temperature so dips in low temperature
cause dips in the dta so concord noiret
are able to respond to that cold signal
better or faster than the Venera
cultivars this is what it looks like if
you overlay them just so you can get an
idea now mind you none of these
cultivars experience damage they were
all plenty Hardy but it's still
interesting to me that the hybrid
cultivars are able to respond at points
when the benefit cannot respond or do or
chooses not to does not respond and so
I'm interested in understanding if that
is a trait that correlates with the wild
germ plasm if that's something that we
can select on this is an example of the
data that Tim martinson's group puts up
for farmers so farmers have access to
this data throughout the winter so they
can make choices about their pruning
technique whether or not they need to
account for damage to their vines you
can see in 2009-2010 Cab Franc and
riesling well well below the hardiness
line needed if you look at Cayuga white
and concord to hybrid varieties you can
see that they're much more responsive in
the lt50 curves and then if you look in
the 2010 2011 season net again at
concord you can see that's very reactive
to temperatures
so I'm really interested in
understanding what the control is of
that ability to move the other thing I
wanted to point out is that these
changes in LTE our temperature
responsive it's not like a age over
winter it's responding to accumulating
cold temperature pictured on the left of
this graph graph are ripe area cuttings
one kept in the cold room one kept one
collected from the field on the right is
volcano same situation called room and
field and you can see that with the
field exposure to cold the LTE values
for the field ripe area and the field
bullpen are much much harder much lower
than if they were kept in the cold room
under those dormancy inducing conditions
so I want to understand what promotes
the change in hardiness and what the
physiological mechanism is behind it
this is the data from this year looking
at Elte values obtained from wild germ
plasm and you can see the Viva nephron
and hybrid genotypes a picture on the
right hand side of the graph in color
all the black graphs are our bars are
wild germ plasm and you can see that it
far exceeds the ability of Bennifer at
this early point in the season I've
color coded ripe area blue and vulpan a
pink here so that you can see that
there's wide variation in the ability to
get increased cold hardiness within
species within ripe area we're seeing
six degrees difference between the
samples were looking at and in ball pen
or seeing a four degree difference and
I'm wondering if mid winter hardiness
and D acclamation right can be pulled
apart this VIP area on the right hand
here from Iowa represents this negative
17.6 level of hardiness the one on the
left from Manitoba represents the
negative 23.5 so the question is if
you're super Hardy does that make you
always d acclimate quickly so are these
separate modules that we can select
apart or or is it one adaptive complex
that's been transmitted through time and
so
we got a we're working on figuring that
home the last thing I wanted to tell you
about was trying to get at the
physiology behind what could be in
increasing the bud hardiness and so we
looked at whether or not sugar type or
concentration could determine cold
hardiness in these four varieties that
Tim martinson's group works on we have a
lot of data from other perennial systems
and also from grape that suggest that
cold hardy varieties tend to have higher
sugar concentrations and that dormant
buds at least with grape tend to
accumulate higher levels of raffinose in
hardy buds than insensitive buds so we
looked at the sugar levels in those four
varieties Concord noir a cab franc and
riesling to see if there's a correlation
between there bud hardiness and sugar
throughout the whole season so the four
sugars we look at our pictured here at
the bottom glucose and fructose
monosaccharides sucrose is a
disaccharide of glucose and fructose and
raffinose is a sucrose molecule with
galactose added on and so these sort of
represent a carbohydrate pool that could
be moving back and forth between
trisaccharide and monosaccharides States
and so we thought maybe maybe one of
these sugars will tell us something
about hardiness but it could be that
it's the flux between the four that
actually have something to do with it so
this is what it looks like if you look
at sugar concentrations in those four
varieties cabernet franc and recently on
the left side concord and waray are on
the right and what I want you to notice
is that sugars oscillate greatly
throughout the season this is the same
winter season that we just looked at but
hardiness so they go up they go down
they always seem to go up and down
together so there doesn't seem to be a
pool trade-off where we have sucrose
decreasing and then glucose and fructose
increasing but that all the sugars seem
to more or less be moving together the
other thing I want you to notice is that
concord and ra tend to have much higher
sugar levels
for all sugars as well as total sugar
than the tuvan Effra so if we look just
at glucose and raffinose you can see
what I just explained that concord and
waray noir a have much higher sugar
levels throughout the entire season and
that riesling which is the more Hardy of
the tube in AFER's also tends to have
more sugar so it looks like the sugars
are correlated with but hardiness but we
wanted to test this by looking at 33
different wild varieties to see if maybe
this is just a cultivated phenotype or
if this is something that occurs across
the whole genus because what we don't
see is the sort of correlation that you
would hope to see between sugar and dta
values so pictured here on the left is
Concord on the right as Riesling the the
top colored line is total sugar and I've
just collapsed all four sugars together
because they cycle together and so it's
easier to look at one line than it is to
look at four so you can see how sugar
total sugar levels cycle throughout the
winter pictured behind the sugar is the
daily temperatures and then on the
bottom is the LT 54 Concord and so if
sugars were playing a direct role we
would expect then as the lt50 decreases
in Concord I see sugars increase in
opposition if they're the the driving
mechanism we do see that the coldest
point in conchords hardiness correlates
with the highest point in sugar but it's
pretty arbitrary difference between high
points we look at Riesling we see it
something very similar lots of
oscillation without changes in hardiness
and no dramatic increase in hardness
that correlates with sugar level so it
doesn't appear that the sugars are
driving hardiness
it does kind of look like sugars are
cycling with winter temperature and this
might just be because I stare at these
all the time but it looks a little bit
to me like at least in the beginning of
the winter here Concord seems to be
cycling at sugars along with changes in
highs and lows after our first real cold
freeze the sugars kind of depart from
that pattern and I don't know that may
have something to do with fulfillment of
dormancy or some other physiological
marker that we haven't covered yet so
right now we're looking to see if the
sugar level correlation falls apart when
we look at lots of different varieties
with lots of different hardness levels
and we also need to make a point of
noting that there could be some other
environmental parameter like our winter
maybe our winter was it was awfully warm
and perhaps these correlations start to
fall apart and when you have less severe
winters there's lots of other parameters
that we haven't considered yet the final
thing I want is leave you with is that
these are all characterization and
phenotyping research projects that were
getting off the ground to try to
understand which traits are the good
ones to go after for breeding we're also
taking a genetic approach to mapping
some of these cold hardiness traits
there's several segregating populations
between hybrid varieties and wild
varieties and we'll be screening them
for chilling requirement budburst LTE
and Ozma light levels and pictured here
is just an example of what we've been
able to look at so far this is sugar
level in one segregating pipe or one
population pictured in the two blue
arrows in the bottom left corner are the
print the parents of this cross so you
can see that the two parents produce
almost essentially the same amount of
sugar in their buds but their progeny
produce this huge transgressive array of
sugar concentrations and so we're hoping
to look into this some more and see if
we can figure out if we're starting to
pull traits apart
so I'm just going to wrap up with that
cold stresses culture and cold hardiness
is a suite of traits it's really
complicated and we're working on trying
to pull things apart into manageable
bits the wild germ plasm that we have
access to carries variation in these
traits and we need to draw on those
traits in order to improve great term
plasm you can see from the cold
hardiness that a cold hardiness of
vanilla that both Riesling and Cab Franc
kind of go down the middle of winter but
they table off so there's a lot of
opportunity for us to improve grapevine
the mechanism of cold hardiness really
isn't clear at this point sugar level
might have a role in it but it does not
seem to be the driver at least with one
year's worth of data and please stay
tuned this is the first year I'm hoping
to come back several times and tell you
more and more as the story progresses
and thank you for your attention I'd be
happy to take questions
well so not with the four that we're
looking at though they were all moving
in sync it's possible they're being
hydrolyzed from starch reserves we did
not look at starch that's the only place
that I know where they could be coming
from no that's a great question in a
great point this hasn't been corrected
for anything like that and the the
investigation into the responsiveness
for hardiness that we just initiated
that this year so hopefully I'll be able
to give you a little bit more input on
that after this year the samples that
we're running include both male and
female vines but as you pointed out the
are germ plasm is not run like a
vineyard we don't control crop load we
don't control vigor at all and so really
I need to team up a little bit more with
a bit of culturist who could give me a
hand with understanding that we could
probably deploy some things with fruit
removal in a in a vineyard setting and
see how that affects it but right now I
don't have the answer for you though hmm
so the reason we kept them at five
degrees because that's the temperature
of our cold room but the literature on
chilling requirement is the chilling
portions that perennials tend to count
begin below seven degrees c and stop at
zero so we want to keep it in that sort
of sweet spot for chilling fulfillment
so we could definitely try treating at
zero over the long term I don't we would
have to make sure that the plants were
acclimated sufficiently so they could be
held below zero for you know 2,000 hours
but um but it's a good comment okay yeah
we could do that we um the driveway just
to give you some background on the
method there we tried processing these
buds fresh will fresh from the LTE
experiments and found that when we tried
to process the mechanically process them
and grind them up and they were wet that
we got less sugars extracted
because of the way that the grinding was
working so we've been freeze drawing
them in order to make polarization
easier but your point it's good and it
would be easy enough for us to take
fresh weights mmhmm yeah yeah it's it's
probably pretty slight given because
these buds are very tiny and they weigh
very little to begin with but it makes
sense that if they're increasing their
osmolytes yeah I think that's very
interesting question I don't know if
rootstocks impacts ion hardiness but if
we need to try maybe grab the same sign
on to a bunch of different root stocks
and watch based on based on what we
expect the buds to be going through in
winter there they're more or less
physiologically sealed off from the cane
hopefully they're responding on their
own and if that case if that's true then
I guess you wouldn't expect rootstock to
contribute much except for roots
actually contributing much through the
growing season so we could definitely
test it yeah no I think you're right
it's it's another trait we could be
looking at and having an impact on it I
haven't looked on it mostly because I
don't know a whole lot about wood
physiology and so I'm a work in progress
but um it makes sense that if you had a
greater capacity to transport
carbohydrates that perhaps you could
elevate that level prior to winter and
come start off at a heart of your level
the only thing I would say is that we
expect that the buds are not drawing on
the cane tissue so much throughout the
winter once they've once they've shut
down the paradigm has moved through the
leaves of siness we're not expecting
there to be a ton of communication
metabolically or molecular Lee going on
but we don't know so
I'm hoping for the sooner rather than
later I don't know when I don't think
it's so much of the price point it's
untangling how messed up the genetics of
gray pine actually is so if you look at
Vanetta it's super hot heterozygous
these are combinations that performed a
long time ago and preserved in the state
so when you compare between varieties we
run into a lot of problems just mapping
no jeans because they move inversions
deletions is sort of thing when we move
to the wild species you know it just
gets crazier from there I can tell you
that we're all the whole g GRU group is
interested in pushing forward sequencing
in these wild species and we've been
working on it trying to get some of the
wild species as a reference genome so
that we can when we do those mapping
populations we need to be able to mark
map the markers and at this point we
still lose a lot of markers because
there's no reference location for them
in vanilla so we're working on it I
certainly hope it's in the next years or
so we did the Iowa ripe areas in there
and then we also have one from Quebec in
that study as well that's not south but
I thought our experiment wasn't working
when I got that data because the
Manitoba right queria went so quickly we
have collaborators in South Dakota who
also work with this ripe area and
they're ripe area takes fifteen hundred
hours our experiment it took nothing and
so we kind of put our heads together and
thinking about that and one thing to
note is that there's chilling going on
before we get the cuttings it's not a
not anywhere near 2000 hours but every
night it gets cold it's that clock is
going there counting so depending on how
your fall transition from summer to
winter is how steep that transition is
that can really change what that zero
point is and so what we came up with is
in South Dakota where you have a rapid
transition it's hot hot hot short fall
deep into winter
it counts a lot slower because it can
only count every time that comes back up
above 0 0 and 7 you know so takes a lot
longer under that climate here we have a
lot of cool nights so it starts counting
way before we can actually go to the
germplasm a make Darmok cuttings so
that's what I thought is with why
something so northern would appear to
not need chillin at all I think it
really does need chillin it just starts
that clock much earlier than we are able
to measure so this year we've got we're
counting chillin hours prior to our zero
point to see if that changes our scale
at all and we're doing it across a much
wider swath yeah yeah november seventh
was was when we did it because we we
need to wait for the plants to go
dormant enough they drop their leaves
that can go out and cut cuttings from
our germplasm some ripe areas are very
photoset if they're if they're well
that's if the clot if the photoreceptor
clock is tied into the cold clock in
that case and some repairs are very
photoresponsive and they drop their
leaves well in advance of the first
frost and others hang on to it and i
don't think i have that data from our
germ plug in this year in this year's
study that we expanded the ripe areas to
include we have one population from
Texas we've got exceeding the Texas and
Iowa and Manitoba and we're hoping to
see things start to pull apart there
I saw this year to our Asian varieties a
mere ensis bursts very early and so they
were all leafed out when we had that
that scary frost and the vanillas were
still quiet they they were safe but I
did see a lot of burning on the stuff
that burst in our germplasm and I agree
with you completely in that within a
vine you could go out there and it was
almost like here it took out all six
buds and this whole vine over here is
totally fine and then in the next vine
over it's every other bud and I don't I
can't think of any reason that there
would be site to site location
differences I suppose there could be
something along the lines where certain
buds incurred a non-lethal amount of
damage through the winter which makes
them more susceptible to frost in the
spring they're just weaker bursts and to
us they look fine I do think the
microclimates a possibility if you get
an eddy or just a local drop of a few
percents of a degree it might be enough
to cause that lethal symptoms so yeah
I'm not sure we would have to cat we
would have to categorize it right yeah
yeah and that's ultimately we want what
I would love to be able to say I
deployed was grape vines that have green
shoots that come out in the frost in the
early spring and it doesn't matter what
frost you get they have a greater
capacity to shrug it off so that's
probably take a couple more years though
thanks
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu